going right now for Hans camp hey it was
some kind of just good to be here my
name is Hans Kim and I have a lot of
confidence right now a lot of people say
to me hey Hans you're book smart but I'm
street smart
you're smart going that's not measurable
or comparable I could be for you maybe
you're not smart maybe you're dumb and
you're insecure about it and that's you
committed aggravated assault that's not
smart that's not crying stop punching me
it hurts this lady's bondus Lee who
cares about that
[Music]
is what I think about your big break
plenty of dark seats over there just
that's the one see you can't sit in a
good white people plants any better
this one is it right good I never said
[ __ ] my eyes are smaller than others I'm
Asian or was announced in Chinese
[Laughter]
because whenever people are racist to me
I'm like oh you name it special people
who keep to themselves okay cuz I'm
finding an affordable car you don't have
to stay away from me that's a lot of
pressure she's like I'd say I stayed
awake for this
what you want me out for every fun
I know they used a dick and I don't
think it's small because they're racist
but even if it was small and it's nice
pretty big but even if it was it's not
like we'd hear that they're like oh we
got small dicks okay we'll go find a new
hobby sorry to bother you see you guys
Buddha just came up we would start
studies that's what we do we put how to
use' like a sewing machine a lot of
things I don't understand about English
in America they say president don't drop
the soap
that's not even helpful it should be
don't pick up the soap
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm going over that Willie gets it don't
help the soap you're still gonna get
raised I'm just gonna really clean hands
all happens
who are these rapists like man I want to
get that kid but don't take no for an
answer
women I'm glad that women give birth
about man because I feel like a man gave
birth you feel like bro I've been eating
so much protein and creatine this baby's
like 27 pounds
[Laughter]
the first trimester this one girl was
like did you know that my vagina is a 3d
printer I was like that's not even
accurate you were with a 3d printer your
vagina is the tray it's not even a very
good 3d printer it only fits one thing
with lots of errors it takes nine months
to print and the whole time as printing
is complaining
I love this topic I was like dude were
so lucky were not gay can you imagine it
was the tempter that we were attracted
to wasn't attracted to us back I was
like well can't even imagine it was
quite constantly thing is that's not
that that's very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]